november 2021
um
we only have one item before us
which is the application for the grant
of a full variation
to a premises license under section 34
of the licensing act 2003 at people 183
ashley rhode hale
um now
just do some introductions i'm
councillor david jarman i'm chair of the
panel and i have two other councillors
with me on the panel which is
councillor's books and thomas
we also have office offices from the
legal licensing and democratic
services teams
who whose identities will become
apparent as we go through the hearing
now do we have
the applicant present
yes my name is alan other kid
sorry
okay and you're you're here on your own
yes i am yes i'm the operation manager
of the company yes
right
okay um
[Music]
right so we have representatives
[Music]
well
um miss ali from the environmental
health
uh
the environmental health officer
could you make yourself known are you
there
hello
good evening
chair hey
get rid of this message on the screen
um
councillor patricia young you're here to
make a representation
yes thank you very much
hello
we do have some members of the public
here so could i ask you to
identify yourselves please
okay so
i'm claire lipsley and i'm a resident at
number two westgate
and i'm joseph keowski resident at three
west gates
i'm judy rose resident at 16 west gate
right i know you're all wishing to speak
tonight
yes plea i would like to make yes yes
yes both
two of you um
right
wanting to speak
i would like because i don't want to
speak thank you sorry patricia no i
don't want to speak i'm just listening
thank you that's fine that's fine but i
gotta ask when you do speak try not to
repeat
the points that the other the previous
persons made that's okay
just to be clear we're here just for the
variation which is the two hours
extension in the morning from eleven
o'clock to nine
o'clock
and the change of the of the trading
name
um
which just escapes me at the moment
um
plus the changing of the changing of the
the new dps
so what i'll do is i'll run through
the procedure for the meeting
and then
and then we'll start the meeting so
firstly i'll ask the licensing officer
to outline the application
i'll then ask the applicant to address
the subcommittee
and call any witnesses
the applicant and each of their
witnesses that may then be questioned by
members of the subcommittee officers and
any other party making representation
um or we can ask by the way we can ask
questions of the licensing officer
when they present the the outline the
case
excuse me
the party making representations you'll
be referred to as the representative
will be given an opportunity to address
the subcommittee and call any witnesses
the representative and any of their
witnesses may then be
by members of the subcommittee officers
and any other party making
representation
if there are more than one
representative they will be heard in the
following order
so in this case we have the
environmental health officer
um the two public or three is it public
representation
and then uh council the young
after this i will request all parties
involved to summarize
to summarize the representative or
represent representation will be given
two minutes
to summarize
followed by the applicant who will also
be given two minutes to summarise
then the subcommittee will just consider
their decision and then i will announce
the determination of the application
and the reasons for the determination
this will be confirmed in writing within
five days of the hearing
so is that everybody clear about the
procedure
yes sir
okay can i ask for the licensing officer
um to to outline the application please
um hello um can everyone hear me first
of all
yes okay thank you um i'm katie
armstrong i am the licensing officer um
thank you chair and members of the
subcommittee this application was
submitted by dana jackson on behalf of
the premise license holder middle
eastern concept limited this is in
respect of the premise quran restaurant
183 ashley road hail
the applicant has applied for full
variation to the current premise license
and the following changes have been
applied for
firstly to change name of the premises
from quran restaurant to people
secondly to change the designated
premise supervisor
and finally to amend the opening hours
to read monday to sunday nine to
midnight
the operating schedule has been
completed by the applicant and it
contains additional conditions to
illustrate how they proposed out to
promote the four licensing objectives as
required through the license act 2003.
these are outlined in paragraph 3.2 of
the committee report
officers believe that the application
has been properly made and all correct
procedures followed
the application including the current
premise license and the current premise
license plan
have been attached as appendix a and c
the blue notice is attached as appendix
b
during the consultation period a
representation a representation was made
by nashoreen ali an environmental health
officer in relation to public nuisance
specifically in relation to noise
this is attached as appendix d9
as further eight representations were
made from local residents in relation to
the prevention of public nuisance
the prevention of crime and disorder
public safety and protection of children
from harm
their local ward councillor councillor
patricia young
also made a representation in respect to
the above
all of these are attached as appendix d1
to d8
the subcommittee is invited to consider
the application and the representations
and decide to either grant the
application in full
grant the application with amendment
amendments or to reject the application
uh thank you chair
ms armstrong can i i just ask you
in the email you re the nazarene's email
that you refer to the environmental
health officer
it said that there have previously been
a number of complaints
about the establishment i just wonder if
we knew about any more detail about the
nature of the complaints
and and over what sort of period of time
and and was there any action taken by
the restaurant
um i can revert back to you um in about
two minutes if that's okay to find that
information
yeah that's fine
do we want to press on with the
to hear the the applicant or does that
uh sorry are there any other further
questions for the licensing officer
sorry katie
is everybody okay about what the
licensing officer said about the outline
yeah okay
in that case can i ask the applicant
please have outlined his application
for us
okay how so so basically we ask
three things for
changing and that's the first one we ask
for is to change the trading names
from kareem to people from current sorry
to people
we ask the second things for changing
the dps you know
from muhammad
father
and then we just ask for change the
hours of the operations from you know
eleven o'clock to 9 a.m
not to sell alcohol at all so you know
because you sell breakfast and all that
that's the three things to ask for
is that all you want to say at this
stage
yes sir
hello okay did you say
the extension of hours from 9 to eleven
is not to serve alcohol
yes sir from nine a.m till 11 a.m we're
not serving alcohol
right
basically we're not changing the
licensing so
okay and sorry you said you changed the
dps from the form of gps
yes sir
but are you the new dps or who's the new
dps
we have a manager on the side he will be
the next dps
right do we have a name does he have a
name can we are you able to
say who it is at this stage
so the application is under the name of
adam karim but we're changing it under
the name of george perrick
george sorry
just so we're clear about who the dps is
george
yeah it's g-e-o-r-g-e
yeah
and it's very
it's v e
r a
k
george okay
now
on the plan it wasn't
particularly clear i think it was an old
plan you submitted with the application
uh that related to a previous uh
previous incarnation of this insta
establishment it didn't show the outside
area at all
so i just want you to be clear about
what area you're actually
licensing
is it is it the whole area minus the uh
or is it my the inside area not the
output
sure we're not changing the licensing
everything stay like how it is the
inside to the outside we're not changing
any license in basically
right so there's there's no drinking
alcohol outside
it's just for two hours
yeah basically from nine o'clock to 11
a.m there's no alcohol we don't serve
our goal at all
right
okay all right um i'll ask if any of my
colleagues on the panel have any
questions at this stage
counselor bob
or counselor yeah sorry it was just to
clarify on the point that you're making
you know something like the externally
uh is there at the moment
uh
just for
reference uh
an existing
survey of service outside
of the the the code cute lids of the
curtains of the the premises
say say the question again sorry say
again about outside
i was just saying is there any
business being undertaken outside of the
the
property itself
yes but between between 9 and 11 there
is no alcohol allowed at all we're not
changing the license basically we're
just asking to amend the time from 11
o'clock to 9 a.m for the breakfast rate
we're not selling an alcohol so the
license stays like how it is
okay thank you
can i ask then is the is the outside
area
license from eleven o'clock
it's it's in the news yes it is yeah
it is
yes it is licensed
from eleven o'clock
right
yes
counselor but do you have any more
questions counselor talk sorry counselor
thomas
yes uh
the signage on the property already
shows the name change to people doesn't
it mr kadami
say again sorry the the signage on the
property
at this moment in time
is for people
nothing has changed yeah it's changing
outside yeah outside already yeah it is
yes say people hail yeah okay
um that will do for me for the moment
thanks david thank you
so so how long have you been operating
under the new
guys effectively
about under the new
the people and i would say about two and
a half months yeah average of two and a
half months
right and i'm using the outside area
yes sir correct
right okay
right is um i'll just ask if there's any
more questions of the environmental
health office to have any questions
or the applicant
no questions chair
okay does any member of the public have
any questions for the for the applicant
and can i ask to restrict the questions
about
about the application and what what you
said tonight rather than making
your representations at this stage
thank you mr chairman so it's claire
lipsey i've just got a question um can
you confirm that you are
not serving alcohol
between
nine and eleven a.m because you are
currently operating the restaurant is
currently open from 9 00 am the outside
area is open from 9am and alcohol is
advertised as part of your breakfast
menu could you therefore confirm whether
alcohol is being served or not i've seen
this
yes i can answer that question my
confirmation to all this and i can
confirm there is no alcohol being served
between nine and eleven we don't serve
alcohol but the license have not changed
the license still the same the only
thing we're pushing back is for the nine
o'clock a.m so we can serve breakfast
you know days coming in people can sit
down outside inside we're not doing
alcohol at all
counselor mr chairman can i just i don't
know if you can see um a copy of the
menu um that shows the breakfast menu um
from 9 a.m with alcohol
being served
that's that's that's an old menu
basically the money is
and we have seen people being served
alcohol
i'm sorry i'm not aware about that at
all so the money's been changed
the website has been dealt with and
people serving alcohol
it's not allowed to be served from nine
o'clock
thank you in any event the restaurant is
open from nine a.m when the current
license um
says that it can be opened from 11.
yeah the restaurant is not open from
nine at the moment we didn't open from
nine basically it's open now we're doing
it from ten o'clock trying to get the
stuff in and then we can you know
come can we just clarify
yeah the
the outside area has been used from nine
o'clock that's a categoric statement
alcohol has been served
from nine o'clock
that's it that's outside well it's not
even supposed to be seated
so as you want to clarify that
how can i do it basically
yes yeah i love this debate
i mean
clearly the applicant's saying that from
from now on i suppose whatever's going
on in the past and that there are
allegations is not stuck to the
the previous licensing regime
necessarily that that it will that
they'll be saying now that the it's
it'll be open from nine but there'll be
no alcohol served
so
we we would you know issue you know
restrictions uh conditions to restrict
that
so i think whatever's happened in the
past we're now looking at a new
licensing regime which you'd have to
adhere to
or you you're able to
to ask the licensing section to review
the license if he breached it would that
be
would that be licensed to drink alcohol
outside as well mr chair
well not from 9 11 is is what he's
saying
let's go sit outside we don't serve
alcohol from nine to eleven sir
can i just clarify the cartilage that
you're referring to
um
on the planet forgive me if i've made a
mistake here but it looks as though the
premises actually doesn't extend to the
cartilage
outside on west gates could someone
clarify whether whether
whether the licensed premises includes
that curt includes the outside area on
westgate whether the licensed premises
just includes inside could someone
please um
clarify
currently the plan that we have is from
2016 and all of the area inside is
licensed and but they do have a license
to
have off sales of alcohol as well so the
consumption of alcohol should only be on
the premises which is the area they do
not have a area outside which is
currently licensed based on the plan
that we have okay so can i just clarify
then um the this application is that to
um open inside the restaurant
inside from 9 to 11
and alcohol won't be served inside from
9 to 11 sorry yes between 9 and 11
and alcohol won't be served
outside at all
because because there's no there's no
application there and that doesn't form
part of the license premises can i just
clarify that
we've not had a change of plan um so
that is correct
thank you
sorry sorry just one sec just sorry just
i've just got one last question
and i hear what you're saying mr chair
but i just it's important to me as a
local resident that
alcohol is advertised as being served
from 9 to 11 not off the website and
then this is the current website
right well clearly
he's not he's not including that in this
application so from now if he breaches
that then you can ask for a review of
the license okay thank you sir
i'm interested in does it does the fact
that it's got off sales allow people to
take alcohol off on onto the um to the
the outside area the pagoda
basically
i just wonder if our legal officer can
clarify i
yeah i can i can commit katie may want
to come in here as well so currently
they are licensed for on and off sales
so
um if the plan um is just the interior
of the the uh premises then that's
covered under off sales but the external
area can be covered under under off
sales um it it all depends on the the
area that we're talking about if the
entire area including the external is is
in the plan then they're covered under
on sales so ultimately under off sales
they could still purchase inside and
take outside what does make a difference
is where the purchase is taking place if
customers are
seated externally and are placed in an
order externally and then it's being
brought out to them that's the that's
the point of of sales so
it wouldn't be covered that would be
classed as an on sale and they'd be
outside of their
um
license zone uh katie are you happy with
that that how i've explained it yeah
yeah thank you
will it be covered by by off sales then
the applicant would need to
confirm the method of sale and
our customers seated and then a an order
is taken from the table
uh it would be really helpful if the
applicant could just elaborate on that
right
could the applicant please clarify
yes
so
so basically when you know we're doing
it that way when the customer go to the
bar they ask for their drinks they pay
at the bar you know and that's how it is
yeah
but they can't they do you you're not
intending them to take the the alcohol
outside onto the into the pagoda
is that right
yeah so basically what i would like to
say from forward from now on and forward
basically we have to do it in the way
that you know the the customer will take
the drinks you know they buy it from the
inside to the outside if they want to
buy the drink they can buy from the
inside but for us to serve it to the
outside we don't do like a you know we
don't serve it to the outside
no but you could well that what you're
saying is it they can take the drinks
outside
because of the the off sales clause
yes allowance yes so you did say in your
application
alcohol is only serviced on the premises
for the consumption on the premises
but you're obviously including the
outside area in that
yes
right okay as long as we're clear about
it
um
just basically we we want to say that
the alcohol is not served between the
hour of nine and eleven and that's only
for the sure you know to basically clear
all that
so can i just be clear then um from 11
a.m
from 11 a.m um alcohol
can be served
in that outside cartilage providing
patrons
go in to the bar
by the alcohol and come outside what
can't happen is that patrons sit at a
table in that cartilage and um
a member of staff comes and takes an
order and serves it am i clear that that
is not
what is being applied for and currently
is not and is not what would be allowed
to happen
well if you're asking me i would say
yeah i mean it it's clearly the outside
area is not not um licensed for on sale
so
you wouldn't be able to sell alcohol
there but because of the off sales
clause people are able to take their as
it is at the moment
from 11 o'clock they're able to take
their alcohol onto the
onto the the outside curtain i would
just like to say at the moment it's
possible to sit at a table and place an
order for lunch with alcohol
actually to place an order from 9 a.m
for alcohol and it'd be served to you at
the table
outside
outside there's no cleaning commission
for that yeah that's that's what's
currently happening really there's no
planning permission but we i mean that's
correct correct and that's but that's so
you know when you're you're not
concerned with that this evening we
don't want to use any waters but there
is no plan
yeah but but just so we're clear
currently that that's what's happening
without planning commission
very technical really isn't it but well
it's i think yeah it is very technical
mr chair and i think obviously we don't
want to merge any waters our our
concerns our licensing and planning i
know we're only concerned with licensing
here but
we just as residents just want to be
very clear about what is allowed at the
moment what is happening at the moment
and what's going to be allowed going
forward because at the moment there are
there are serious breaches of the
existing license
and obviously going forward then we need
to
make sure that he sticks to the
conditions of the
the license
um
or
i mean you could have previously
somebody could have asked that one of
the residents could have asked for a
review of
these um
of these breaches of the well
with respect count with respect mr
chairman we have we've been writing to
the licensing
authorities that we've got a list that
they advise us to keep a diary of
breaches which we have kept and which
i've shared as part of my um
opposition to this application and i'm
not sure whether you've had the
opportunity to read those and but but
they are there and they are clear
we have been making we've been making
representations since the end of july
when people opened
right can i i think this is probably a
good point to bring back the licensing
officer
um katie did you manage to
to uncover anything about the previous
complaints
um nothing
very significant to licensing because a
lot of it did relate to
planning
um there are some very historic the
premise just for context was first
licensed in 2005
um
and that are historic complaints from
back in 2005
um most recently there was a complaint
in june of this year 2021 um in relation
to a jet wash
um
which was causing disturbance to
residents
an enforcement officer
followed that up and there wasn't any
follow-up from the resident um apart
from that it's all based on planning
recently
sorry
sorry sorry that that that complaint
was made by me um
i didn't receive any um no communication
at all
but from the licensing that they had
followed that that up and i have also
sent you a copy of the um
menu serving alcohol from 9am um if you
give me a moment i can check my emails
to let you know when exactly that was
received and on advice from councillor
young and from um someone in planning we
have all been keeping a diary
and because that's what we were advised
to do and if we if there was any other
steps that we should have taken it would
have been appreciated if those could
have been shared however i i have quite
a comprehensive list um and if you've
had the opportunity to look at my letter
of the 7th of october all the breaches
are listed there
yeah we have we have seen them yeah
thank you not just yourself i think
three or four of the residents yeah
thank you this is this is an ongoing
this is an ongoing um some of these
matters are probably you mentioned
planning they're probably something to
take up with the planning enforcement
officers oh
um breaches of the license the alcohol
license these are relevant to this
hearing i would hate and i would hate if
they were
overlooked because we have somehow
misreported them because just because we
have misreported them
doesn't mean that they haven't happened
and and these are all licensing breaches
rather than planning breaches
well yeah okay moving forward this is a
new application so i think from here
we'll we'll
if it's if it's past obviously if
um and then it's subject to conditions
then we'd have to make sure that they do
adhere
to those conditions and we would rely on
the residents to to to make the
licensing section aware
of any breaches and then and then we
could follow that up
so i think moving forward
whatever's going on in the past would
have to basically
you know almost have a clean sheet
really and say this is a new license
um and then we'll we'll have to we'll
have to take take those issues up with
the applicant
so can i ask has anybody else got any
got any questions for the application
for the applicant at this stage
chair could i just
intervene very briefly at this point
just want to clarify um on something
that the applicant
raised earlier he states that he's not
requesting um a change of the licensable
hours to serve alcohol from 11 until
nine but that is what is on the
application he's made um i'm just
wondering obviously what licenses view
on this i think we need to differentiate
between operating hours which are on the
the operating schedule
what we're licensing is the the um
times to serve alcohol and i think the
applicant just needs to confirm whether
he
is intending uh the committee to make a
decision on um
the hours or whether he's actually
keeping them as a as an 11
am start for the uh sale of alcohol if
that makes sense
yeah basically we just you know we keep
the operating hours basically we don't
want to change the license or what we're
asking for is from the 1911 and that's
the breakfast time there's no alcohol
being said at that time that's what we
want to do basically
so you're prepared to amend the
application because i think
what the legal office is saying you've
put it in the application from nine
o'clock is that correct
deserving of alcohol
i think i think katie can you confirm
that as it stands he's actually
requesting that yeah the license is
varied so they're permitted to serve
alcohol from 9am but if that's not what
they're actually asking for then i think
it's
um perhaps a discussion that's
not really necessary at this point if
he's prepared to
remove that
seems to be saying he is is that correct
mr kareem
yes it is collector
okay
thank you that's mr kidrani speaking so
thank you
yeah sorry about that nobody knows
i want to clear that it's from 1911 so
we don't sell alcohol that's you know we
stick with the rest and 911 we don't do
alcohol so yeah
okay thank you is all right are there
any further questions for the applicant
please sure
yes
mr clement if if your intention is not
to serve alcohol
and your website states that there is
alcohol available with breakfast between
nine and twelve i think i've noticed
that the um
the breakfast menu is available
can i ask why you've got alcohol on that
menu
so basically on the website you're
waiting for that to be amended and you
know which engine you know is basically
going to change you know
he's going to be amended on the website
i appreciate that but you've been
operating as people for two and a half
months by your own admission today
and
in two and a half months you still have
said
uh that your menu still state that
alcohol is available with breakfast from
nine o'clock
now two and a half months in by your
admission
um
i i don't know when when it was changed
but we'll take we'll take it as read
he was on the menu correct but we were
not serving it from that time to a
certain time you know it was not
available from the nine o'clock till you
know
but you've been open since nine o'clock
since you two and a half months ago
saving breakfast
so ideally when we open we open for two
weeks from nine o'clock but then
we change it you know and we change it
from you know ten o'clock and we haven't
been busy from 10 o'clock because when i
went past today
there were people sat out in the uh the
seating curtains at the side
on on the road in question uh sat at the
square tables with the wide tablecloths
on it whilst you're having those
deliveries occurring at the same time
i'm just concerned
that
you're aware of the licensing being from
11 o'clock
yeah you've tried to open from 2 o'clock
you've changed the name already at what
i would imagine because the signage is
very very proper
uh very nice signage to people
and you've tried opening nine o'clock
and now you're saying you're open at 10
o'clock which is contravention of the
license that's in place at this present
time a little bit concerned of that and
the fact that you're out your
your your menu
offers alcohol from nine o'clock
yeah
you know that's my concerns
i appreciate that going forward we can
put special restrictions or conditions
on your license
but i'm concerned that you're ignoring
them already because you only have a
license from 11 o'clock
11 o'clock and you're opening at 10
o'clock sure
of course yeah i mean i wasn't you know
from the previous what's happened before
i wasn't to work i don't know what's
happened before but i can assure you
from what we when we've done this
application now everything will change
you know we're doing it in the right way
before before for now i have to deal
with it in the way we don't serve
alcohol between 9 11. this is the three
things we're asking for you know
changing the trade name we're not asking
for nothing else we're changing the dps
like we said and we're changing from you
know open time 11 o'clock we're changing
from 1911 so we can attract more
breakfast we can attract more customers
to our breakfast there because you see
the moon this morning this morning you
have customers
sat outside before 11 o'clock
i'm not worried about that yeah well i'm
not done
because i drove past it i wanted to have
a look
and you didn't have time
which is in contravention and you've not
given me any to my mind
a valid reason for why you are opening
up either inside or outside at this
present time
when your license doesn't allow you to
and i'm concerned that if you're going
to flower a licensing law
that that states you can't open until 11
o'clock
what's going to happen regarding the
alcohol that's my concern and you've
given me nothing other than say you're
not going to do it any further
to suggest that you're going to adhere
to any conditions that are put on the
license i'm concerned about that i'm
concerned about
what the residents
are alleging
and having seen something with my own
eyes i'm just concerned that you you're
not addressing that you're not
addressing how the regime going forward
will
adhere to conditions and may or may not
be put on the license
i do respect your concerns and i can
assure you you know basically
we this application has been not
not ever over a month now and you know
the concerns you had i take them very
serious you know we've been trading for
how long now we just need to keep up
with the trades like i said to you and i
can assure you this will not happen and
that's how it is that's how it is
exactly what changes have to be made i
want you to be as uh in the area with
support as well the area and i want to
make sure that all the changes we're
asking for it now is by the book that's
how i say to you
okay thank you chair
thank you fine yeah i mean we can tie it
down with a new application then
rely on the residents if if they if they
spot any breaches we can follow that up
is there any further questions for the
applicant
in which can i just ask as far as i'm
aware he hadn't responded to
the
environmental health officer um
email and
um
it was the outstanding issue of the
noise management plan i don't know
whether in receipt of that but it
wouldn't be able to
start operations really until we had the
noise management plan in place
and also that there was a suggestion
from the environmental health
officer
of a 10 am start on the sunday
so a bit late to start on the sunday
um
[Music]
for the outside area would he would you
be prepared to um to accede to that
[Music]
yes sir we are happy about the 10 a.m
on a sunday
right and you and you go you produce
you're going to produce a noise
management plan
uh we should open from a sunday if you
can trade from 10 o'clock and then we
can pursue that so yes yeah i understand
that what about the noise management
plan are you going to um
produce the new one to cover the license
or you're going to rely i believe there
is one in place with the old license but
whether that's sufficient
we can basically relate to that so we
can look to it as well so yeah i'll bow
to the environmental health officer's
superior knowledge on that um
in which case there's no more questions
for the applicant i'll i'll um
refer to the representations and i'll
ask the environmental health officer
first miss ali if um she'd like to make
representations about the application
yes sir thank you very much chair um
basically um i've reviewed the
application uh based upon what has been
sort of applied for um so my comments
are based upon you know the actual
application um as when it came in
and also the applicant that i've been
dealing with is a mrs dana jackson i've
not dealt with mr adam kareem or
mr kidrani in relation to this
application um but basically i was
consulted on the full variation
application for the premises um and my
understanding is that the application
proposes to change the hours the dps and
the name of the premises um the
application also states that alcohol is
served on the premises for consumption
on the premises only
the proposal is generally for the
premises to close 30 minutes earlier
than currently permitted and open two
hours earlier than currently permitted
and from an environmental protection
point of view closing 30 minutes earlier
is acceptable and um opening two hours
earlier um one day to saturday is
acceptable however on a sunday and a
bank holiday um a 10 a.m opening time is
considered to be more acceptable
generally because they're more sensitive
sort of times and people would generally
want to rest in their premises also on
those days um
further clarification was sought
regarding the serving of alcohol off the
premises
from mrs downer jackson
but i've not had any contact from her
since the 7th of october and 2021 um
the application site is in close
proximity to a number of residential
premises on westgate and the pollution
team have been in receipt of noise
complaints relating to the premises over
the years
the main noise complaint being noise
from refuse and waste collections before
the permitted time specified on the
license
there exist various planning and
licensing restrictions which have
prevented noise relating to the premises
and the external elements of the
restaurant
these restrictions and conditions have
proved effective in controlling noise
from the site for the majority of the
time
with regard to this particular variation
application in order to achieve the
objective of the prevention of public
nuisance i have recommended that a
number of additional conditions are
attached to the license and that is in
addition to the existing conditions that
are currently on the license
so these are the opening hours so um one
day to saturday 9 a.m to midnight
sundays and bank holidays 10 a.m to
midnight
the second is the production of a noise
management plan for the premises before
the proposed change is referred to in
this application take place there is
reference to a noise management plan but
i haven't received anything um in that
regard so um
it's important that that is submitted to
us for approval uh prior to this use
taking place
um the third condition which is
recommended is that um no music sound
speakers shall be permitted to any
external part of the site
and just going back to the application
in section 3 of 18 in the application
form the applicant stated that alcohol
is only served on the premises for
consumption on the premises
um on this basis i recommended a
condition um to remove alcohol off the
premises um because it gave the
impression that they just have alcohol
on the promise premises not off um
so
it's not really clear where the proposal
is to remove off sales from the
application and i've not had any
feedback from mrs dana jackson or
anybody else that's at the premises or
responsible for the site
um going forward should the proposal be
to remove off sales and only serve
alcohol on the premises for consumption
on the premises i'm happy for the
suggested condition to be added to the
to the license um
if however the applicant wishes to
continue with off sales and serve
alcohol off the premises then i'm happy
for
my recommended condition relating to off
sales to be removed basically and so
that's where i stand in relation to
to to that particular issue
okay mr kidrani did you
you hear that and understand
that well i don't know if you want to
respond to that
mr kid ronnie
we've got your name right this time
is he there
do we have the applicant
he seems to have gone missing mr kidrani
it looks like he's disappeared from the
screen
i think he's gone not in the attendance
natalie can you practice he was in a
waiting room the benefit of the doubt he
made his thing that may have felt like
his signal may have fell off or
something but yeah you can see if he's
[ __ ] in the waiting room
dave can i uh ask
miss ali a quick question please
just to confirm there's nobody in the
waiting room
it looks like he's gone
well i have to say there was some doubt
where they'd actually turn up because i
don't think we were able to make contact
with him until
this afternoon or possibly this morning
sometime today but we were prepared to
hear it
in his absence but we
might have to hear it half in his
absence if you know what i mean
but yeah uh simon if you'd like to ask
ms ali a question too all right good
evening miss ellie uh just a quick one
uh would you
in your inspection would you say that
the seating outside
would
be tantamount to off sales or clients
but do you have an opinion on that
um my understanding is that as as the
legal officer explained earlier on um
if
somebody's applying for off sales they
um
they they're selling alcohol to for
consumption off the premises um so if
it's not defined in the plan then it can
be um
you know it can that can be consumed in
in anywhere really along the course of
each of the premises i i don't know if
the legal officer wants to correct me on
that but that's my understanding
it's only the plan that will uh that
will confirm this for us and and the the
plan if that's on the current license um
as katie said i think the plan that
she's had sight of um the external area
isn't included in it so it would be off
sales not on sales thank you
yeah i think he said he wanted to keep
that off sales claws in just to
consume alcohol on the
the outside area
if i'm right but if we can get it
clarified i think that would be that be
useful
um
did
mrs livesey did you want to make your
representation please
uh
counselor gentlemen i'll start off and
claire will uh join uh will follow me if
that's okay
so i'll um read out sorry are you are
you mr lindsay i'll take it no i'm mr
kiowski of three west coast just i'll
just introduce myself so it's mr keowsky
the three west coast i was right at the
time i didn't realize you were cheering
the screen sorry no no no
do you apologize
no it's okay council of german so uh
good evening my name is uh joseph
keowski i live at uh with my wife at
three west gate in hale
uh we're approximately eight meters from
the pyramid of the restaurant boundary
my wife and i have been residents uh on
westgate for 33 years the main points of
our ejection are covered in our letter
sent to the licensing office on the 5th
of october
main purpose of my representation this
evening is to reiterate the key points
from from that letter
and hopefully convey the effect of an
extension of the license and
uh increase in the current business
activities
in general on our daily lives
therefore
i'm going to make it very clear that we
and i certainly oppose the extension of
the license extension
with no conditions
i'll get to the point that i'll get to
the basis of my opposition uh westgate
is a residential road it's not a
commercial street the residential
character of the road is now affected
negatively
as far as a lot of us are concerned as
it's being used for outside dining and
drinking
the construction of the pergola
facilitates this the addition of the
roof and heating means that this will be
used all year round
and therefore noise persists during both
during the day and the night it is heard
within the household and it's not just
the bins and the emptying of the bins
it's the noise and the clatter from the
uh
from uh from the area there is no
soundproofing there's no barrier between
the restaurant and our property we can
hear noise constantly both from the area
under the pergola but also from inside
the restaurant
um since the doors and windows are
frequently left open
there's been no attempt to minimize the
noise to an acceptable level so i i look
forward to the noise management that
mr
mr kareem mr kadrin
has suggested
from my perspective extending the
licensing hours will only lengthen the
period of disruption and noise residents
have to endure especially given that the
restaurant will want to prepare before
opening hours and clean down after
closing hours
on a concern of public safety it's been
noted that since hail people open there
are more taxis
delivery drivers and patrons
who are parking illegally
at the junction of ashley road and
westgate thus causing serious traffic uh
hazards pedestrians have to navigate
between or around illegally parked cars
potentially causing a serious accident
noted that some cars have been parked
illegally with parking wardens not
enforcing these infringements
the restaurant is open from 9am until
midnight on one occasion the outside
space was opened at 7 45 causing
lots of noise disturbance from customers
laughing talking talking loudly and the
noise of plates and glasses
alcohol has been served from 9 00
a.m and i can categorically stay out and
this has been a
recent uh observation
we've
we've been unable to have our windows
open during the summer just to give you
an idea of the the noise
that comes from the premises
to be honest we have no confidence in
the management of hail people as they
persist in enacting a way which is
wholly inconsiderate to the neighbours
and
rather unprofessional in the way that
deal with the
the local residents when reporting on
issues to hail people which do not
comply to the terms of their licence
there's minimal attempt to make
improvements or have meaningful dialogue
and give timelines when issues will be
resolved
examples of correspondence and
photographs can be followed upon request
but
these were also reflected in the
objection lesson
we believe that tail people and previous
establishments are continually trying to
push the licensing boundaries
and this has a detrimental effect on our
environment and to the local residents
as a responsible managing director of
the plc
i'm expected to comply with regulations
permits have to be applied for properly
and to minimize and make sure minimize
the impact on the local environment and
the community
and
employees with no detriment to the
neighbors
i have to make sure that my application
is done professionally
and on time
and not done in uh
vacillating from i'm going to open one
minute i'm going to close one
i'm going to change my conditions that
cannot happen
but nevertheless um i'll move on
my question is
why are
restaurants given special special or
preferential treatment
as i say residents on
westgate already suffer noise nuisance
and anti-social behavior at all hours of
the day at night
they've endured this inconvenience for
many years extending the license our
tail people does little to reduce
anti-social behavior on the crime in the
center of hail studies show a strong
correlation between the consumption of
alcohol and crime and anti-social
behavior hail is no exception to this
i would urge the licensing committee to
consider undertaking a health impact
assessment in which evidence of the
negative effects of the extended
licensing hours can be uh fully assessed
the premises licensed summary gives the
opening hours of 11 to
12 30
from monday to sunday with alcohol being
available from this time hail people is
open since nine
it's in breach of its current license
we've already said that
and and this has been for four months
not two and a half it's been for four
months
um
good practice states that wider
consultation encourages partnership
and on no occasion has hailed people
shown any meaningful dialogue or trying
to mitigate our concerns complaints
regarding the empty of glassware and
other complaints early in the morning
before license permits have been met
with no action
and a tordry response
the government and licensing department
have committed the use of outside tables
and pavements due to the con the covid
pandemic and to somewhat try to
compensate for the financial losses to
the businesses
however there's no consideration given
to the immediate residents
including my wife who is a key worker
and how and
and many of the residents have worked
diligently through the pandemic
in view of this i would ask the
licensing authority to refuse the
application and to support the
hard-pressed residents living close to
the village end of westgate
and over so
thank you mr kowalski um excuse me sir
can i just uh say something please i've
got the owner's son he just come in now
and he'd like to speak please
okay
okay
thank you
uh hello sir uh my name's adam karim
um
i i basically apologies um i believe uh
alel's phone ran out of battery um
i was in i came to the restaurant and he
just mentioned to me you know that
it's kind of time for me to come in and
kind of hear you guys it was my father
who was dealing with it uh with him uh
i'd just like to say that um
part or
large parts of what uh mr crosby just
said we're incorrect and
for the following reasons um i
personally met with
uh mr kowalski with miss libsy um with
um councillor young
uh and councillor mitchell on two
occasions
um
to discuss uh the operation of the
business how we can improve it on the
latest meeting mr kwalski said he could
smell coffee from seven
houses away and that was a big concern
to him
and to which i'd said well
it's fresh coffee there's not much you
know i i doubt it can be i'm not so
calling you a liar but i doubt you can
smell it from so far down the street um
but you know i i would love a small
coffee in the morning fair enough
everyone is different i'm not sure how
we can change and amend that and
we had a really positive discussion with
council young um
counselor mitchell and ms libsy and mrs
koski which whom the latter two have
never been into the property to enjoy a
drink since they opened they've
obviously not been supportive of that
local business
now um so i would say that across that
point of there's been no dialogue that's
in the first instance has been two
physical meetings more than that and
miss libsy and mr krauska have my own
personal email and because i'm a bit
more practical than my father to kind of
try and assist you know uh where i can
you know um
now
i've got probably no less than 15 10 15
emails i'd say um between both of them
where they've raised an issue and i've
come back with that comment so we're
trying to improve this okay i've heard
what you said on that i folded
correspondence two email chains between
myself which is you know private and
confidential to a point and the bin
company um where i've stated is on our
license it must be collected after this
date you're running a risk of losing
your uh like your contract with us you
need to stick to the rules where we're
pressing on these companies but
obviously we're relying on third-party
companies to do this job um we're making
sure that lifts are done with
environmental agencies uh kind of
foresight making sure the bins are
collected frequently to make sure
there's no
overflowing of pins to prevent any
rodent issues
and
the woman on the first house the lady on
the first property we fixed her offense
because the previous guys had broken it
and as again goodwill for the
neighborhood we see ourselves there for
many years
you know just trying to build
relationships up we offered the whole
street a and the whole westgate street
only we offered a discount card for
coffee to come in to enjoy the coffee
mornings and so all these are steps to
try and build relationship with the
community but
the whole fact that the fact that you
know mr koskinen
lifts it hasn't even attended for even a
coffee i think shows where they see this
site and kind of you know how they they
just didn't want to support it from the
start
now with the the um
the the premises opening from nine um
it actually opens from ten uh which
appreciate it
it's in breach of its current um the
current license because it should be
from eleven we've had this license
application i think over six weeks and
where we tried to kind of resolve this
and
straighten any wrongs which is why the
reason this application actually went in
for such minor adjustments i mean really
like your licensing um is it the lady
lisa uh miss grimshaw she mentioned it's
more of an operational time than a
license in time because that's all we're
really asking for we're asking for
operational hours so when we're talking
about um crime disorder uh nuisance all
this kind of stuff i think moving from
11am to 9am i think all that kind of
falls away i'd say that is more
predominantly in the evening and
especially because we're we're open the
same there'll be no alcohol served at
that time um and in regards to the um
the customers being served outside um
again without open dialogue with
mrs young without open dialogue with mr
mitchell we've heard what license that
i've said the team have said here now
and it'll be made sure going forward
that anyone who drinks outside will be
purchasing inside
um
in relation to the the app that we add
in the noise survey um
i'm happy to get a nice survey um
taken um
but it wouldn't make much sense having
one taken without having use of the
space otherwise what are we actually
saying
there's no difference because it just be
as it was so i'm happy to instruct that
um if that if that kind of
uh makes everyone feel a bit more secure
and happy that you know there's more no
more depth being taken to it i take the
resident's um
kind of objections and and
comments and feelings um very seriously
um hence the reason why miss lucy on
several occasions has been
you know emails back and forward where
she told me this has not happened and
you know i've got dialogue down with the
managers guys what's going on and then
passed on to my father my father's then
spoken to the managers so
we're definitely proactive um
even to a point where i've had to with
the bin company um we've asked that and
i did mention this to mr krosko but you
know due to either annual holidays my
builders being away being sick looking
after his um partner as a midwife so he
had to look after his child his daughter
and we'd even put locks on our bin store
so we can manage the refuse company i
mean it's a measure we shouldn't have to
do when you're using huge companies but
it's something that we've instructed and
again that's something i'm having to pay
for to put locks on my bin store to call
out a joiner this is all for the local
residents it's not for me so
when uh mr koski says that we're not
supported and we don't listen and by
extending the times from 11am to 9am
he's going to increase crime and
disorder in the area and the fact he can
smell coffee from seven houses away i
just find it a bit far-fetched to be
honest
i think it comes on the public nuisance
basically
what they're saying is the disturbance
at that time
and clearly even before that when you're
in breach of your uh
your your um
new licence
agreement
since it was brought to our attention
sir about the the alcohol um can't be
served before 11. the managers have been
told yeah and i've actually got emails
to back it up from my father where they
have been told no alcohol should be
served before 11. the menus have not
been reprinted and the website has not
been changed but the managers have been
told to not serve and to be honest with
you sir we don't even benefit i mean the
restaurant is not
very busy anyway and secondly nobody
orders alcohol in the morning
i don't even think maybe twice per week
they've said to customers when they've
ordered an alcohol we can't serve it i'm
sorry it's not on our license um so all
we're asking for today sir is is an
operational change not a licensed change
we're not changing the licensing hours
at all we're not trying to extend
um our licensing hours we're not trying
to
pull the wool over anyone's eyes what
we're trying to do is rectify any wrongs
by putting the correct dps which is
something that we need to do as a
licensed premises to make sure the place
is properly protected by a dps we're
asking to change the name that is above
the door
and we're asking to open from 9am
instead of 11am so we can serve some
breakfast
right so you're happy to correspond with
the
um with the neighbours
uh because it's one of your conditions
that you can have regular meetings and
you're happy to give the eat your email
contact on
the mobile phone number
yes sir miss um mrs young has got my
email
so is mrs libsys so was mr crosby
they've also got my phone numbers
my phone number
and they've all got it it's always all
in open communication with them um and
yeah we're more than happy to do that
and also on we're happy to move it till
10 a.m on a sunday i can
appreciate that you know no one wants to
walk up early if they can have a line on
a sunday i'm absolutely happy to say on
a sunday it's from 10.
okay all right so that's in response to
the environmental health officers um
findings really has any anybody got any
further questions for the environmental
health officer
sorry sir can um
that was all missed because i believe
oil's phone went off would you actually
mind
summarizing what was
from the environmental health officer
yes that's right would you like would
you like just to summarize what you
previously said
yeah it's just not going back overall
ground really but for the benefit of
mr adam's
just before i do that um i just want to
um
advise that it's sunday's and bank
holiday so 10 a.m on a sunday and a bank
holiday and not just sunday
and that's fine yeah so basically i just
sort of um
summarize the fact that um the comments
that i have made as a representative are
based upon the application that was
submitted to the the council
and that requested um there was
reference to alcohol from 9 a.m till
midnight and i've made a number of
recommendations a number of um
conditions recommended number one was to
ensure that there's a noise management
plan um the hours restrictions and um
there was also a condition about not
having any external uh speakers or music
on site as well um i just wanted to
point out that i've been liaising with
the applicant who i understand was dana
jackson and um i didn't receive any sort
of feedback from her i required
clarification on a number of issues
particularly relating to off sales um
but i've not had anything really back
from um from dana of from sorry to
interrupt dana no longer works with my
father she left two weeks ago so
apologies that that's being lost
right okay there's no longer her name on
the application or it shouldn't be her
name it should be your your name i take
it yeah it will it will need to change
so because um dana's that don't expect
to take time off um so i'm not i'm not
sure when she's coming back so she isn't
two weeks ago
for your company
no
as of two weeks ago so she wouldn't be
on it at all then
no we need to change that please
all right okay we can arrange that um
can i just ask miss ali whether
did you consider whether the
sound screening would be a proportionate
measure
to assist with the with the noise
control at all um the thing is there's
there's an important consideration and
that is the planning permission for the
site so that is the key issue in this
the the premises are not permitted um
for um outdoor seating
in that area to be used i understand
there's a certificate for lawful
development permission which allows for
um
customers to be seated sorry to be stood
um drinking and so on and but um as it
currently stands there is no permission
for
um you know any um
no planning permission for customers to
be seated in that external area that was
highlighted in two separate uh public
inquiries one in 2008
and uh 2017 as well um so that point has
been um sort of highlighted
numerous times and really that that
aspect those conditions restricting the
use of the um
sort of outdoor area to be used as a
seating area have proved effective in
preventing noise complaints relating to
customers and
you know sort of kitchen noises and
things like that
the very nature of the the proximity of
the residential premises to the outdoor
seating area dictates that noise
complaints are likely to be
you know inevitable we've had just going
back to complaints we've had i was
looking through our system and the
environmental protection team have had
13 complaints um
three were in 2005 they related to the
extraction ventilation system air
conditioning system um
two were received in 2008 they were they
related to refuse collections um one in
2011 relating to bottle collections and
then we had further complaints in 2014
16
17 and 19
mainly relating to um refuse collections
bottle collections and so on and there
was actually an abatement notice which
was served on the premises um in 2005
and 2014
and the notice in 2014 related to
refuse collections noise noise relating
to refuse collections
um
so
the important point is that that
the planning conditions uh prevent or go
a long way to prevent um you know
disimmunity to to residents um
and the license obviously that permits
off sales um and
um customers
can there's no restriction in them sort
of
um
using the external areas for
for for the off sales my understanding
that's my understanding
mrs ali can i just come come ask you a
couple of things to write on what you
just said just so i understand it so
obviously the abatement had nothing to
do with
um since my father's took control of it
because obviously they predated him and
when you say noise issues kitchen can
you be more specific please
what i mean is for example if um
if
if the the premises are used so if the
outside area was used as a seating area
the likelihood of noise kitchen noises
noise from cutlery noise from customers
and not unreasonably enjoying themselves
would be audible um at the nearest
residential premises but because there's
planning controls in place preventing
that from occurring and that has hasn't
happened to a certain extent although
there have been occasions where it has
been mentioned and
so
your comment is uh on cutlery is quite
specific it actually brings me to
a past appeal um regarding the outdoor
area where the word cutlery was
specifically mentioned it's actually
quite surprising now you mentioned that
one word as well i mean um
well
yeah so the inspectors specify cutlery
when you say kitchen i mean if you used
to say kitchen to me i would think of
something totally completely different
but when you say kitchen you mean
cutlery i mean that's just something
so kitchen noises associated so if you
have um the seating area being used um
then there's inevitably going to be
noise associated with the internal
elements of the premises um as a real as
a result of windows and doors being open
waiters waitresses coming in and out and
so on so there will be some internal
restaurant noise potentially kitchen
noise and also noise associated with the
customers sat outside or stood outside
dining so you know laughing enjoying
themselves um glasses cutlery dishes
the whole multitude of
noisy activities uh which is
restricted
okay i just wanted to ask the question
because i know that in the conditions
sorry to interrupt you um
on the past um
on the past appeals decision notices
that i've read they specifically
mentioned cut the research once it's you
know just in quite a while you've
mentioned the same word although it's
obviously many years ago but i'm just
going back to the point of the bb
permission and that is obviously was was
given by robert generic under the
chronovirus measures and that protects
or allows use of the space up until
january 200 the 1st of january now
there's been lengthy discussions between
a george england and my planning guys uh
in relation to that outdoor area
now um everyone has kind of spoken um i
mean ralph has emailed me uh
as of last week there was con
conversations between george england and
himself
um and what it confirms is we put an
application for the pergola between
george and my planning officer they they
kind of and again this is planning not
to do with this but it just answers your
question and they they agreed to
withdraw the application um
and the um and my uh ralph uh my my
planner said we will say we'll take that
pagoa down on the first of january as
the rules state as these rules given by
robert generic states so it was using
this outdoor area now the state is not
allowed it actually is it's covered
under the bb class and that was given um
i think brings that one point about the
planning and the seating and everything
i think
that answers all the questions because
we're allowed to use the space under
class vb we're using the space under
class bb and we will take it down from
the first of jan and won't use that
space from that from that date obviously
it's covered by
planning which they've given an
exemption for and obviously we can't
enforce planning regulations but they do
have stronger powers than we do so um
all i would say is if it's not taken
down then
it's of course
people to contact the planning
enforcement office um to to take up that
issue and they would have to deal with
it at the moment
it's got
the existing application licensing
applications got a right for off sale so
we can't do anything about that
could i just take up the issue of the
event the kitchen ventilator uh with
miss ali what what what could be done
about that well again i have to i've
just sort of tried to highlight the
history of complaints so
what i need to point out is that was a
complaint in 2005 we had three separate
complaints and they were resolved um
successfully by various forms of
mitigation so
um
they're not current complaints about the
extraction system um can i just add one
thing with regards to the covid
situation obviously we're in unique
circumstances and there are um sort of
allowances that have been made for
restaurants and so on to
allow customers to be seated outside and
um
there's no sort of there's no question
about that whatsoever um
the pollution section was consulted on
the planning application which mr um mr
kareem refers to um and a representation
was made by ourselves with with regards
to the retention of the of the pergola
and my understanding is mr kareem has
withdrawn that application um and um
to the website yes
yeah yeah so that's correct
okay
fine all right can we we need we need to
move it on can i
can i ask uh councillor young to oh
sorry simon thomas yeah just a quick
questions from a scream is it a quick
statement really it's not a noise
um survey that we're looking for
it's a noise management plan whether for
inside or outside we need to know what
you're going to put in place
in respect of merging the noise coming
out of the property
that was during today and i appreciate
that miss jackson has moved on
but that's what we're looking for not a
noise survey but we're looking for what
you're going to do to mitigate the
effect on the environment locally that's
what we're at
okay mr thomas um to kind of answer that
uh question as it currently stands um we
close the door
to westgate as per the license i think
it's 10 a.m uh sorry 10 p.m so from 10
p.m the west gate door is locked
for customers so the only people who
leave that door from 10 p.m would be
staff right and they're not obviously
exiting the premises to go wherever
they're on a duty of work so
um
that is part of the license that is
adhered to i've been on site you know um
occasionally at that time and i can tell
you that is being done um
i don't want to drag on with a long
dialogue about what's going on so what
i'm saying is we need an evidential
written noise management plan
that's it full start what you're doing
is fine if you're doing things to
mitigate that's great we need to see
what you're doing we need you to put in
writing so that we have something to
judge against
no but are you happy to get that via the
channel of mrs young because i know that
she's been like the point of contact i
think it's the environmental officer
that needs uh needs to see that i think
it's in the conditions that you've
offered in the operating schedule isn't
it
yes and the conditions are licensed and
that's one of them about like the
disbursement of customers can't be
offered um
to the environmental health section
officially okay
um counselor young
do you wish to
please represent
oh hang on mrs
yeah sorry i've just got one very quick
point in relation to planning and i know
we're not concerned with it but i just
want to make the appointment um clause
bb those structures that are um
allowable under covert restrictions and
movable structures the pergola isn't
movable it's concreted into the floor
i just want to make that point so that's
a breach that's a breach of planning
there's a breach of planning and there's
a breach of licensing both of those
things have been going on since people
opened at the end of july not two and a
half months ago four months ago the end
of july
okay thanks for that
councillor young
this has been a
very very difficult um situation to deal
with right from the beginning
because as the local councillor for hail
central
i'm interested in helping
local businesses as much as i can
because we want them to succeed and we
want them to make a profit
on the other hand i keep stressing
that
it's also important that our residents
can go to sleep at night in peace and
quiet and their children can have a good
night's sleep that is important as well
this particular case has been
actually quite difficult to deal with
i'm sure you you can appreciate that
the
application that
they're talking about now the
all the restrictions that have been put
onto the
license that are currently in place most
of these came about through discussion
with the previous owners it when the
hail bar and grill was there and they
were very anxious to get on and to work
well with the residents and a lot of the
a lot of the things like the times that
things could be done and everything
were
arranged with them and it worked with
them because they observed the
conditions that were put in the license
this sadly isn't happening
with um mr karim i'm sorry adam i have
to say this deal and i've made it quite
plain
every time we've talked
what the council's recommendations and
rules were and that you you have to
abide by them
because that is the only way in which we
can work
i would like to ask
that if you are
considering carrying on with the license
that you ask that
bottles and rubbish
are not taken away are taken away are
not taken away i'm sorry between the
hours of eight o'clock at night and
eight o'clock in the morning just to
make sure that there's no banging about
or anything
and also that the
people using the door in westgate
again if they could stop doing that much
earlier than 11 o'clock but something
like maybe eight or nine o'clock at
night but people should come and go from
the door into ashley road
because it's
there's usually noise from people when
leaving a restaurant is when they're
coming out and they're closing the door
and getting into their cars and saying
goodbye to each other and that makes
again a lot of noise in the street so if
if that could be
changed to maybe after
8 pm
rather than
whatever it is now
um
[Music]
also the other important thing which
again isn't happening
is that while the restaurant is
operating
i would like all doors and windows to be
firmly closed the inside of the
restaurant can operate on their air
conditioning
but while they are working and with the
windows open
noise will come out into the street
um i'd like just to ask um
nasri and ali one question
um
i'm fairly sure
that some years ago again i think
probably
going back to the start of when the when
it was hail bar and grill or maybe even
before did you not do a noise survey
from one of the
houses further up in the road
and it was established quite how far the
noise actually carried
and
i feel sorry for the residents because
there's nothing more tedious than having
a child woken up at night because
there's been a burst of laughter or
something that's nine or ten o'clock at
night when small children have been put
to sleep and you probably noticed from
reading the letters from the residents
that there are a number of houses that
do have young children in them
in the vicinities
so
that is something that needs to
needs to be considered
and
again there's been mention of i mean
it's it's it sounds as though people are
being picky when you're complaining
about things all the time but when there
are so many
so many
things that are not being adhered to
then things really do get very very
difficult
to deal with so
i hope that you can maybe consider the
residents and their problems
when when you're considering how to what
to do about this license
um
i'm slightly worried about the provision
of live music that is going to be taking
place
in the premises as well
sorry mrs mr we're not looking to change
that
condition it's not in the variation
counselor young so we can't consider it
as such
you see we do feel that what we
when i talk to mr karim he always agrees
that he'll do everything we ask him to
do
but then it isn't done and the residents
come back to you and say no they're not
doing this
how is what you know how can one deal
with it it's really it's
we've got a new variation now we've got
hopefully a fresh start from everybody i
think we need to enforce things if
things have been done that have been
agreed
i mean i've been working quite closely
with the enforcement officers both for
licensing and for planning i mean i had
a conversation with george england just
a couple of days ago
and it is quite clear but at the moment
there is no permission for chairs and
tables to be
used outside the premises
and yet
there they are
so
um like you said it's it's um
it's one for planning but very simply
put the the boundary of the the unit the
outdoor space sits within the boundary
of the unit so that is covered in the
class bb
well i think what i've said what i have
to say
okay okay thank you councillor yeah i'm
sorry if it's been rambling a little bit
but who no
you know it's very valid what you what
you said um
so mr kareem you have any questions for
councillor young
um
if mrs young would would um i mentioned
earlier on that i'd have two meetings
with the local residents
based on what mr koski has said that
there'd been no communication um can she
confirm that those meetings happen
please yes you did attend two meetings
i think it was twice and your mother
actually came to one of the meetings as
well
so
quite early on this was the meetings
that took place in about june
or july and we also had a later meeting
with councillor mitchell and myself and
you
but i mean
i actually went to the restaurant at
about 10 o'clock in the morning with one
of my with my granddaughter when she was
staying and we were this is
the beginning of august
and we had a cup of
coffee i had a coffee and the child had
a drink and this was at about 10 o'clock
in the morning and there were two other
tables occupied at the time so you have
been serving
meals
before
before
11 o'clock outside
yes
you know it has been made clear you you
said you didn't but you
no message um what mr khadrani was
saying i think earlier was that they
were being said there's been alcohol
yeah since a certain day well i i i saw
what you're saying and yeah i just
wanted to ask that point about the
meetings really
okay
does anybody have any more questions for
mrs young
counselor you sorry
no
okay what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to ask everybody to sum up in in
two minutes basically um
the case
counselor uh german um
mrs libsy hasn't had the opportunity to
speak and uh
but before we get to that i just can't
have clarification who is the license
actually in whose name is it who's the
licensee who's the applicant now who's
the applicant now
well clearly it's not the woman
that is on the license because she's
actually left the company so we're going
to have to change that and i think mr
kareem
confirmed that he would um
yes sir i mean
it is it's definitely not ideal and a
poll we do apologize for that
the amount of movement within the
hospitality business with staff with
issues aren't constantly ongoing is is
meant it's not ideal at all um for us to
do the easiest thing uh and and the
really the wrongful thing would would
have just been to left everything as it
was
uh there wasn't a review put in or asked
by the residents although there had been
complaints or sorry i think we said i've
done sorry can i just ask
who is my license my question is quite
simple who is
okay
so yes sir so for that reason apologies
that there's been a few changes um going
on so the applicant has obviously
changed from dana uh we're gonna have to
obviously update you with the new new
applicants details and uh mr varek who
will be the dps um his details will be
folded as well with his premises license
number etc
mr karim are you permitted to
um hold a license
i've got a license
so
can i just
sorry check can i just intervene at this
point here uh i'd like licensing to come
in and clarify this my understanding is
that the premise license holder is
actually middle eastern concepts katie
can you confirm that
currently is middle eastern concepts
limited um and we also i'll just check
the gps for you as well
the um the
shareholder the director only director
and person with control and interest in
middle east and concepts limited is mr
kareem's that's right isn't it
the career
are you the licensed
i believe so yes
sorry forgotten his name is the dps
mr virek is the one who will be
yes put it into putting the dps in his
name yes i think we'll need to get that
in writing and uh unchanged on the of
course yes
okay um sorry mrs lindsay you wanted to
make a representation
yeah hi sorry i don't want to um
reiterate what um joe has said although
i obviously support
all of that all he said and i just want
to make a couple of observations um in
relation i think to planning because the
point is is that
there is no planning permission for
there to be chairs and tables out there
and i don't accept that that pergola is
a movable structure and as miss ali said
quite rightly said because of the fact
that
there's been no planning permission to
have chairs and tables out there for the
11 years i've lived here the noise the
environmental noise has been largely
managed there have been issues with
emptying the bottles in unsociable hours
largely speaking the residents have been
protected because of the planning in
place the problem now is is that mr
karim has come and built his pergola
without planning despite the fact that
we the residents with councillor young
made representations to him whilst it
was being built and he's completely
written roughshod over over what and
what we have said in our representation
so to date we've been largely protected
we're now not protected because he is
trading from under that pergola the
issue with the lies that the license and
the off license thing just makes that
even worse because actually
as far as i'm concerned off license is
someone where you're going somewhere you
buy some alcohol you drink it outside
outside yesterday speaking but that's
the cartilage of his building
so i don't believe that he should be
allowed to have off sales because that's
in breach of planning because people
aren't able to sit there
sorry i'm not looking to change the
licensing activities
well from 11 a.m
it's not clear mr quinn what you're
trying to do it's not clear who the
applicant is it's not clear
it's not clear
sorry can i finish it's not clear what
you're applying for you've actually been
acting in breach of the current license
since you opened at the end of july
because you have been open at nine
o'clock and you have been serving
alcohol
what whatever you say whatever it says
on your menu well you absolutely have
and and we know that you have and to say
that you haven't it act to be fair is
completely disrespectful and insulting
so those people that live
on this street
sorry i'm just making my i'm just making
my representations then i'm quite sure
that you'll have the opportunity to
answer them so as i was saying you have
been open to the end since the end of
july serving alcohol
in breach of the license it's not clear
whether you are seeking to extend your
operating hours or your licensing hours
it's not clear
okay um
thank you very much thank you
in relation to the noise management plan
um i understand that should have been
attached to your application it hasn't
been attached and actually the point i
would make in relation to that is that
all these conditions in in the licensing
objectives in your application that all
relates to
the premises and what's happening in the
restaurant actually you have a
responsibility and a duty to consider
residents my daughter is of school age
and is frequently disturbed by the
breaches of the license there are five
or six houses in the ten houses on this
end of the village where there are young
children no account seems to have been
made of those that's not only
is it in relation to the protection of
children from harm but also the
prevention of public nuisance and in our
in our informal dealings in our formal
dealings via counselor young i have not
seen any evidence that you have made any
effort to address any of those concerns
so so my firm representation to the
council is is that the license shouldn't
be
extended from 9 to 11
and
and it should in fact it should be
reviewed and then in terms of the
license from 11 until midnight then
there should be quite serious
restrictions placed because sadly
the evidence from the past four months
cannot be overlooked i understand what
you say chair about things moving
forward however
you know the evidence is so overwhelming
that that our needs haven't been haven't
been um
accommodated
can i just come back to that when you
finish please
um
have you guys been on the mission
yes thank you
okay mr green okay just to make it clear
on the three points so you're saying
there's a bit not too sure so the first
one is
changing the trading name
that's point one
the second is changing the dps
the third one is
changing the operation hours of
operation
from 11 a.m which they are currently to
9 a.m
not to serve alcohol from 9 to 11
and taking on board what you've said
about the noise management plan and
school kids in the media area
most school kids have to be up before
nine so i'm sure it's not going to
disrupt any of their mornings
that's what i've got to say just to make
points clear thank you
okay
right can i um all right so
um
natharie would you like to uh sum up
your
what what you said earlier really your
case
your representation
yes uh thank you chair um so basically
um
it's important to point out that there's
a
a current license for the premises which
has
a list of extensive noise conditions um
aimed at the prevention of public
nuisance and it's important for the
applicant to comply with those and
secondly in relation to this variation
application um i would recommend that
the opening hours are
in line with my recommendations
that the applicants submit the noise
management plan as discussed
uh for approval um and also that no
music sound uh or speakers shall be
permitted to any external part of the
site um
that's all i have to say in relation to
the the uh the actual
variation application as long as those
conditions are um
attached to
any variation application um i would not
have any objections to the um
increase in hours two hours in the
morning and um a reduction in 30 minutes
um in the evening
okay thank you
um okay mr kiyokowski
would you like to sum up your
your representation please
uh
can i just have uh can i just have a
moment just to just check over my notes
is that okay mr
council of german yeah no problem yeah
okay
in the meantime can i just have a quick
word
yes counselor
yeah it's just a quick question for uh
miss ali uh you know in terms of the
the complaints what percentage of
complaints have been about uh the refuse
collection
just as a matter of interest from him
right okay so i mentioned that there was
13 complaints since 2005 um
and
we in 2011 there was one complaint about
bottle collections
um
one in 2014 two in 2016
and one in 2017
two in 2019 so the predominant noise
complaints have been about um
the refuse collections and the bottle uh
collections noise associated with that
particular activity um and um
in 2014 a noise abatement notice was
served on the premises um for that
particular activity there is a licensing
condition which restricts the um
the um collection waste and refuse
collections for the site as well
sorry can i just come in okay so very
far sorry counselor is it for actual
collection of the
of the recycling or is it for
actual the the business
basically putting the bottles in the bin
or is it both
so condition seven states that no
bottles to be emptied externally more
refuse collected after 2300 hours or
before 7 30 hours monday to
saturday 30 on a sunday so it's
condition seven of the current life
it does cover both actually doesn't it
yes all right sorry about that thank you
right right
if i could just continue on that one
the point i was trying to make was that
if the the there's been an increase in
say the refuge collection complaints and
that
concern is obviously uh even the council
itself has struggled to try and get the
collections done at the right time or
you know
on the right dates the
thing is how much control has the the
management got in terms of being able to
control that when they're collecting
when they're not because
it's really at the whim of when the
commercial people
who are the collectors do it so uh
do they
who is going to be responsible in terms
of
if there's a you know
the license is done uh it's just a case
of how much
the the the responsibility then is going
to be on the noise management plan the
the business itself
even though he may not be able to
control when it's collected
or how it's done you know whether it's
they've done in a conscientious way yeah
i mean i can talk in relation to
experience from this night ultimately
it's mr kareem's responsibility or the
owner of the premises has a
responsibility to ensure that all
licensing conditions are being met um so
from experience in relation to this site
and other sites um if there are issues
associated with waste collections um
it's easily sort of dealt with by
contacting the um
the waste collection company and
basically if if they can't comply then
you know there have been circumstances
where
waste collection contracts have been
cancelled um and other companies who can
accommodate um
the restrictions are sort of brought
into place so
living ventures i think they were the
organization that was responsible for
this site in the past and um every time
there was a contravention or
the odd occasion when um the condition
was not being complied with and living
ventures contacted um
the waste collection company and the
situation was was resolved i think to
the satisfaction of the residence and
then complaints sort of
subsided and then it's not something
that's happened you know frequently it's
sort of like two a year one a year that
kind of thing and so it is easily
manageable um
well yeah they i mean they just have to
rearrange the rounds so that they're
collecting that less sensitive
properties later really and sticking to
the to the conditions that they have to
adhere to i mean we understand there's
been you know a couple of lapses maybe
or so
but i think you know we need to make
sure that they strictly stick
to the conditions the timings in the in
the in condition seven
so are we are we okay to to move on from
that point if we can ask mr keep keville
kajowski to uh
to give his representation come on come
on okay thank you thanks
thanks councillor gentlemen for giving
me a couple of minutes just to sort of
uh
rethink where we are i mean our position
doesn't really change you know we don't
want an extension of the of the license
you know full stop
however however we would like the
license to be more consistent with the
planning
and
in particular the doors
and windows should not be open at any
time
the door on fronting onto westgate
should not be used
should not be used after 8 pm
and at all
and
in addition um
the bins because obviously that's that
is a uh
a concern
if there's any
refuse that has to be emptied it has to
be within the limitations of an eight to
eight type of
parameters
but again i would strongly urge you to
consider the safety of the residents and
the people in
and around the junction
this needs to be
thought through and
as we said before some sort of impact
analysis needs to be considered
mrs libsy you want to sum up your
representation
um i've got nothing to add to um what
i've already said save that in relation
if there are to be conditions attached
to the license i would like them to be
extended in relation to the collection
of rubbish and the emptying of bins and
i'd like that to be from eight in the
evening until eight in the morning and
i'd also like
the licensing um restrictions to be in
line with the planning and so that the
doors and windows are closed um i would
obviously like it if the off sales um
was removed because then that will
prevent
people that will prevent um alcohol
being served um directly opposite my
house and whether that's from 9 00 a.m
or from 11 a.m until midnight that would
obviously help me so if so if that could
be removed um then i would be that that
would be um i'd be very grateful
for that
and
as we've said already the pergola isn't
legal under under clause bb
and the planning we have largely been
protected um from noise from the from
the restaurant because of the planning
that has been in place that has
protected us and that that protection is
now gone
and and
that's why we're having all of these
issues
so i would ask and i know this is not
this is not your issue this is a
planning issue but i would ask that
licensing and planning work together um
to help to give us some protection on
the face of it we have absolutely no
problem at all with um any of the
restaurants in the village um trading um
if there was some kind of sound
prevention or if things were done in
accordance with the rules then that
would be fine after due consultation um
as far as i can see there's
no adherence to the rules which just
makes it all the more frustrating so
if the committee could see right to and
protect us in some way then that we
would be very grateful thank you
yeah i mean regards
we will consider all these in conditions
but with regards to burglar obviously
they've got temporary consent because of
the code no i'm sorry
it's not a temper structure
for the outside area i believe i mean
it's something that
you need to take up good planning but he
did he did say that he undertakes
undertaken to remove it
on the first difference on the first of
january but what what as i understand it
what class b allows is for outside
seating with temple structures that that
structure is that that structure is
fixed and it's got lighting and heating
which means it which means it can be
used all the time and it is used all the
time
so so that so if there's a breach you
know it's it's a long it's another one
of a number of breaches and i know you
want to look forward and not look back
but it's very hard when we've been
living with this
to have any confidence that going
forward these things will be addressed
and and actually i have to take
exception there's been one there's been
more than one or two instances of
breaches of the refuge collection and
i'm just looking at my at my the letter
i sent to you i can see at least a dozen
in the period that he's been open so
it's not right to say that there's been
two or three and if we've reported them
incorrectly then i apologize for that
but that doesn't mean that they haven't
happened
right okay i mean that's something we'd
have to take on board clearly there's
not a lot of confidence in the
management at the moment so i think we
need that needs to be addressed if the
license is granted
there will be conditions to look up to
take care of the doors and windows and
the bin collections that will be
and we can
prescribe that it's in the operating
schedule and we
we can
we can give you the numbers when we
deliberate
um okay so
can i have my final say sir is that all
right
well you look counselor young first
because she's one of the representatives
and then as the applicant you get the
final say so
young if she wishes to to to sum up her
representation then
we'll take that first if that's so okay
really all i i'd like to say is if you
could
see your way to bringing in the
restrictions that i asked for that i'm
in has just been
highlighted again by by the residents
here
of them
putting just the sights
extra
on on
[Music]
i'm struggling to find the words to
express myself i'm sorry
but
if
we could
at least ensure
that between eight o'clock at night and
8 30 or so in the morning there is quiet
in the street in other words there's no
bottles being thrown into bins or waste
collectors coming and collecting them or
large groups of people going in and out
of the building i mean it's it's we're
not asking for it not to happen we're
just asking for the management to be
done
just more sensibly and considerately and
that way the restaurant can work and the
residents can live in peace
that's really what i'm i hope that you
you can
work for us when you do your
deliberations
so
um
like i think wisconsin said earlier
there was a lot of conditions applied
attached to the license when it was
given
quite a few years ago
to kind of protect the local residents
um the first point was about external
doors and windows
so there's been a couple of points they
mentioned by uh mr korsky about putting
in this no doors and she'll be open and
no windows should be open well these are
conditions while approved by residents
the same residents that approved them
before which was
all external doors and windows shall be
kept closed when regulated entertainment
is being provided
in the except of an emergency
that's all it says on that condition
in terms of the bottles being emptied i
fully accept and
i will say that there has been issues my
father was telling me there's been
issues with the company now i'm not one
to pass blame i'm more than happy as a
person uh i know my father's very
similar to take these things on his
shoulders all right we've we said two
emails to the the the refuse company
saying listening except so i've got the
emails here i folded the last one to the
residence to show them the kind of we
were taking action yeah but in this
condition here it says no bottle shall
be emptied externally after 11
p.m
or before 7 30 a.m now these are
conditions that have been approved now
it seems like this
meeting is about three
two
givens
i mean changing the trading name
shouldn't be restricted unless there's
an issue with the trading name or how it
looks how it's seen and the second one
the dps that's just a standard change
one from one because it's a designated
premises supervisor if that person
leaves the premises needs to be
protected and licensed and operated
properly so that needs to change we're
only talking about the times from 11am
to 9am and it seems like we've you know
people on this meeting are trying to
slip things in at eight till eight i'm
happy to have a conversation with local
residents my father is up his other
conversation my mother is happy to have
a conversation with local residents and
discuss it in open comfort and we have
conversations i've had two myself
well these are not for this hearing now
just hearing now he's talking about
simply 9 a.m to 11 a.m two hours
difference and not serving outcome
we're not talking about planning and
attaching planning to seating and and
you know
we're talking about a trading name
change
on the license a dps change on the
license and two hours in the morning
when school kids will be open will be
awake anyway
if this needs to be reviewed further
down the line that's something different
but this is the conditions that are in
the license
with regards to the refuse and the
external doors and windows are being
followed and in terms of the door on
westgate it gives it to 11 o'clock i
mean this was a condition approved by
the residents
0.8 after 11 hours on weekdays and after
midnight
on fridays and saturdays
no patrons shall be allowed to exit the
building via the main entrance on
westgate now that was approved
those late times have been approved and
even i
just on a gesture of goodwill with
residents have said i will close it from
10. well the license allows me to do it
till midnight
so what i'm saying is is i my father my
mother were happy to work with the
residents they obviously have not been
supported from the business from the
start um mr koski and miss libsy have
never been even been in from what i've
been know by the managers all the
management staff know
these two individuals these two
residents because they're very active in
showing their distaste in certain things
that happen um
so we know they've not been in they're
not supportive of the business i'll be
interested to know ms ali of the 13 14
15 complaints how many are from how many
residents without saying names yeah so
we are supportive but these are the
conditions in the license that we are
following but these ones have been
thrown in tonight about 8pm closing the
door this is not on the license
okay
there's a point of order here surely
councillor chairman well he's summing up
he's that that's his summing up of this
case i mean i i mean
the regard the residents
would you not agree there's some
vexatious accusation there
with good sorry with regard to with uh
own that uh the incidents that have been
reported have only been reported by
ourselves
i didn't say that i said i'd be
interested in
that's the insinuation and i think that
was clear there's accusations going back
and forth we're gonna we're gonna have
to bring it to a conclusion i just i'd
just like to just just ask mr kareem
on regards to the gate you said you
you're happy to
to close that gate at 10 o'clock rather
than 11 o'clock the west west gate is it
that's correct and that's just to build
the relations with the local residents
sir
right so no earlier than 10 you're
saying 10 o'clock yes
the planning does state eight are we
talking about the gate on the door
the planning issues you'll have to take
up with planning we don't have power to
enforce the planning the planning regime
on the bins are you happy to reduce the
time from 11 o'clock
in the evening and actually increase it
from 7 30 in the morning because they do
seem rather well rather early in the
morning and late in the evening would
you be happy to volunteer the answer i
completely agree if i was a local
resident and i heard someone lifting a
glass bin
it's a shocking noise
at certain times i would agree
completely so yeah i'm happy to accept
that and also can i just add to that my
managers they don't empty the bottle
bins at night they just carry the bins
to the bin and they empty them in the
morning
to not make a noise i think it's more to
do with the collection but it's in
they're both covered by the same
condition yeah
i think it's 11 p.m but again i'm happy
to change that two to what eight o'clock
um you know it says no refusal after 11
pm but i'm
to be honest with you there's never a
collection after 8 p.m it's the morning
collection that's just been a bit off
eight o'clock in the evening
and eight o'clock in the morning
yeah so the complaints uh when when i
when i know there's been issues
it hasn't been about evening collections
it's only been about morning collections
i'm happy to say from 8 p.m
you'd have to agree so it's very late
it's 11 o'clock yeah i agree with you
sir i'm happy to move that's eight p.m
i'm just i'm just kind of shedding a bit
of light that it's been the morning
collection that sometimes has gone
wayward um when i've asked for the
collection timings from the waste
company
um
it's been stated that you know yeah okay
it was collected at 6 45 and i said it's
unacceptable it's on the it's on the
license it's unacceptable and i sent
that email to mr i think was miss libsy
or mr koski to say i am is being dealt
with we are on on them so again i'm
happy to change that i'm happy for that
to be amended
okay
so
that i mean you've had more than your
two minutes so i i will we'll finish the
representations there
so
the the
panel will retire into a breakout room
to discuss what's been said and make our
deliberations and then we'll come back
and deliver
our verdicts on on the application
is that okay
so we'll we'll be away for a few minutes
and then we'll come back and um and
give our verdicts on the on the
application
okay thank you very much for now um
just to point out with we're basically
we we're
our remit was to discuss three basically
minor issues which was the which was the
variation
of the license so if i could just
explain that
so i deal with the name change i don't
think that's controversial so that
that's we're happy with that the name of
the dps
is clearly wrong on the on the license
application and we do need clarification
in writing
of who the new dps is
so
to deal to deal with the
the hours change the remit of our
committees is licensable activities with
no no control over what's called
operational hours
which is the opening so as far as as far
as we're concerned the licensing
activities
remain at 11 o'clock
now
it's given obviously a chance up for us
to to renew conditions or out conditions
and
there's 21 conditions on the operating
schedule that goes with the application
so i can just i'll just read out some
relevant ones because i think it's
important for the residents to hear this
really
on the doors
condition for all external doors and
windows shall be kept closed
when regulated entertainment is being
provided
except in the event of an emergency or
for ingress and egress to the premises
condition seven
deals with with bottles no bottles to be
emptied externally
nor refuse collected
after now this this was amended from
2300 hours to
oh oh well 200 hours in the evening
i know 7 30 i was in the morning 208 100
hours monday to saturdays
and 9 30 9 30 hours on sunday
with regard to the use of westgate
so that's been
condition 11 has now been amended to
after 2200 hours on weekdays
sunday to thursday
and after midnight on fridays and
saturdays
no patrons shall be allowed to exit the
building by the main entrance on
westgate road
exemption for disabled persons and those
accompanying them
so in addition to the 21 conditions on
the operating schedule there's three
further conditions
proposed by the environmental health
officer
which we're going to
to adopt
this turn to them
first condition refers to the opening
hours and it has been agreed by the
applicant to
raise the opening hours on a sunday um
from nine o'clock to ten o'clock
um
now the noise management plan the there
is a condition to submit the noise
management plan to the environmental
health officer for
approval
um and this has to be this has to be
submitted within
14 days
of from today's date so the so the
applicant needs to provide the
environmental health officer
with a copy of the noise management plan
within 14 days and then then that needs
to be approved
before the the application can be can be
accepted
and the final condition
is that no
music sound or speakers shall be
permitted in any external part of the
site
now
that concludes the findings of the
committee but just to point out on the
pergola it's obviously a planning
consideration it comes under the
planning regulations
which is a separate regime in fact
stronger than the licensing powers that
we have
and
and anything to relating to the pergola
needs to be taken up with the planning
and planning enforcement
so
that's the decision but what i would do
was urge all parties to talk to one
another and um
i'm i'm sure counselor young would have
to use a good services to facilitate
that
there is a condition about regular
meetings and i think really if you
exchange you've exchanged contact
definition
emails and phone numbers hang on i'm
just delivering the decision you could
speak at the end but the decisions made
then basically that that would assist
in the future operation and i would urge
the applicant to actually
do what he says really and basically if
he agrees with the residents to do
something
then do it and obviously stick to the
conditions of the of the application
okay so that's the decision of the
committee okay mrs lindsay wanted to say
yeah thank you thank you very much mr
chairman i've just got um two queries uh
number one could you just confirm to
whom the license is granted
and number two could you just clarify
what regulated entertainment is please
send it to me
yeah we understand it to mean dining
does it does it is that what it means
dining
uh well it means regulated entertainment
is alcohol live music recording music
and please music okay
okay
yeah
thank you
middle east middle eastern concept
so however
it should it be a person
should have been individual
well there'd be an individual dps and at
the moment the name is incorrect so what
what we've asked for is that that is
confirmed in writing into dps
it will be changed on the
license
so who's actually applying who's the
person
making the application it's just not
it's
yeah
well i understand it's mr kareem but i
mean i need to be confirmed they need to
be
i think he did confirm that earlier
earlier
so i understand that mr karim has had a
license revoked does that have make it
have any impact on his ability to hold
another license
well i don't know about that and that
really should have been said in the
meeting and we could have explored that
we've made the decision
was it wasn't it was mrs jackson miss
jackson he was applying we didn't know
in advance of the meeting that mrs
jackson no longer worked um for middle
eastern concepts and in fact mr karim
only joined the meeting
well i'm not i'm halfway through so to
be fair to us um
it's not it's not clear who the
applicant who the applicant is and
i i yeah and i'm not sure that
you you know who the applicant is
and if you do would you just please
shout out he was asked to he was asked
to clarify it very early on when he
joined the meeting
but he did it but he didn't clarify that
uh counselor i did ask him and as far as
we're going to clarify the dps is and it
will be written onto the application
does it not have to be an individual
not necessarily an individual should
complete the fall but
the main issue is the dps
i know if you want licensing to come
here just to confirm the position in
terms of the difference between the the
premise license holder and the applicant
um katie i'm happy for you to jump in
here but obviously the
premise license holder the person who is
essentially responsible for the
the license is middle eastern concept
and that doesn't need to be an
individual that can be a company
yeah um in terms of the applicant katie
is that just terminology for who's
literally filling out the paperwork
that's correct it's also
middle eastern concepts hold the license
that means that they get any annual fees
which correspond with that license at
the moment looking on companies house we
do have adam sadiq karim he is
registered with that limited company but
it is the limited company of middle
eastern concepts who do hold the license
and they're there for making the
application when dana jackson submitted
the application she submitted it on
behalf of the premise license holder
which is that limited company it does
not need to be an individual the
designated premise supervisor is a
separate
person that does need to be an
individual and
they they basically couldn't have all
the control of the premises they need to
have a bit extra so they need to have a
personal license as well so we will
confirm with the applicant when they
tell us who the dps is we will ensure as
a licensing authority that all the
correct procedures are in place to
ensure that that dps is correct
okay
thank you very much all right well look
that's that's the decision you know and
i appreciate you're not entirely happy
with it but
authority
there are some certain issues you may
need to take up with the planning
relating to to the pergola
but as far as his operating
uh schedule is operating conditions for
licensing activities they they don't
they don't actually change
and the opening hours isn't actually
something we can actually enforce but
you know he said you know he said what
he said and he said you're going to
demolish the pergolas
urge you to do
is obviously set up a dialogue with mr
kareem
um and then and councillor young could
it could obviously assist with that as
she has done previously
and
may you know really need to hold into
account and if there are any breaches of
the conditions of the license
then we will pursue that vigorously
okay i mean from my perspective i think
we've tried to have dialogue and we've
raised the concerns that we've had and
we haven't
we haven't uh sort of made have any
success but
we take on board what you say um
he risks losing his license quite
frankly that's the bottom line
is he is sorry just so unclear sorry if
i just it's all a bit of a jumble it's
so unclear is he is it now licensed to
serve alcohol from
9am and 10 am on sunday
so is it is that he can open at 9am but
do that without the license quite
frankly which is probably something i
didn't appreciate but that's the
situation so we've used all the powers
we can really you know before that
you can't you can't serve alcohol at 47.
okay all right thank you thanks for the
application
thank you for your attendance
it's a valuable contribution that you've
made
and i think going forward we all know
what what we need to do so we appreciate
your attendance and thank you very much
thank you okay thank you sir okay thank
you and i'll i'll now close the meeting
and thank everybody for their attendance
okay thank you